immaginiamo questa scena un bambino un
seggiolone il piatto con la minestrina
quella buona tiepida tra col formaggino
appena sciolto un bel cucchiaio vicino e
la mamma che guarda innamorata il suo
bambino almeno prende il cucchiaio lo
osserva si sporge fuori dal seggiolone e
lascia cadere e il cucchiaio sa cosa che
lo trascina verso il basso la mamma
allora guarda il suo bambino fa un bel
sorriso bambino la guarda sorride anche
lui sventato e stavamo a prendere il
cucchiaio lori's acqua e lo rimette sul
seggiolone del bambino prende del suo
cucchiaio lo guarda di nuovo guarda la
mamma guarda il cucchiaio e lo lascia
cadere
cos'è che lo fa cadere ma ancora una
volta con una pazienza incredibile
atavica chissà da dove viene prende
questo cucchiaio loris acqua di nuovo e
lo rimette sul seggiolone riguarda il
suo bambino bambino pene di nuove
cucchiaio di nuovo sporge la mano fuori
dal seggiolone sta per aprire la mano
quando la mamma subito lo ferma no no no
no no no no no no no no cucchiai
lo riporta dentro guarda la mamma poi
guarda fuori dal seggiolone
e lo fa cadere di nuovo che cos'è che lo
fa cadere la mamma questa volta non
prendi cucchiaio lo guarda guarda e
bambino che vuole insegnare così una
lezione al suo bambino
il bambino allunga il braccio fuori dal
seggiolone cerca cerca di prendere
questo questo cucchiaio ma non ci arriva
e si sporge rischi anche quasi di cadere
e poi comincia a piangere e piange
fortissimo e e urla come se qualcuno lo
stesse e torturando ma a questo punto
come il solito insomma innamorata del
suo bambino con questo con questa
pazienza zen che hanno tutte le mamme
tanti di nuovo il cucchiaio loris acqua
e lo rimette sul seggiolone convinta che
questa volta il suo bambino avrà
imparato una bella
l'elezione il bambino guarda nella sua
mamma fa un bel sorriso vale cucchiaio
prende tutta la minestrina e volere
fuori dal seggiolone ministri non
dappertutto
ecco vedete io mi occupo di teatro e mip
e mi occupo anche di scienza e per me
questo è un bellissimo esempio di teatro
scienza se tutto tutti gli ingredienti
del teatro sono qui c'è un bambino che
l'attore che che ha un problema
vuole capire perché diavolo questo
questo cucchiaino cade per terra c'è una
mamma che ha un altro problema vorrebbe
tanto che insomma meno mangiasse c'è una
soluzione al problema cioè provo a far
cadere il cucchiaino per terra e e vedo
che cosa succede
e c'è un dramma c'è una bellissima
storia d'amore fra fra questi due
personaggi una storia d'amore che
affonda le radici nel dna antico chissà
da dove
perché vedete il bambino in realtà sta
esplorando il mondo facendo questa cosa
facendo cadere il suo cucchiaio
il bambino accende e sviluppa un senso
di curiosità rispetto al mondo nel quale
lui vive e in un certo senso questo
bambino entra in contatto con con tutto
l'universo
certo non è cosciente e certamente anche
crescendo chissà cosa imparerà il perché
il mondo è molto più misterioso di
quello che noi possiamo immaginare però
così in questo modo accende la sua
curiosità e impara e acquisisce una
certa consapevolezza perché il cucchiaio
cade qui così come cade su marte così
come cade su proxima centauri su proxima
centauri vedete questo è un disegno
chiaramente ma proxima centauri è la
stella più vicina al nostro sistema
solare
a circa quattro anni luce da noi proxima
b è il pianeta che ruota attorno a
proxima centauri sono in guardiamo bene
questa immagine che poi è un disegno
però dovrebbe essere così se non
potessimo andare vediamo addirittura tre
perché proxima prossima ba1 e vive in un
sistema solare fatto di tre soli cioè
prossima centauri alpha centauri e beta
centauri che si muovono in maniera quasi
caotica attorno quindi anche
imprevedibile ecco è meraviglioso
questa cosa della meraviglia è qualche
cosa che tutti gli scienziati possiedono
adesso io però voglio fargli voglio
farvi una domanda vorrei che veramente
voi rispondete in maniera molto molto
naturale alzate la mano
se anche voi non sentite qualche volta
ma anche oggi il desiderio di essere un
po come quel bambino che scopre il mondo
io certamente sì fatemi vedere e tutti
allora perché non ci provate questa sera
magari quando tornate a casa da qualche
parte insomma prima di un cucchiaio e
fatelo cadere per terra
vedete cosa succede oppure fatto anche
adesso magari con il vostro cellulare
sarete voglia o cellulare del nostro
amico chiaramente scherzando la verità è
che noi questo esperimento qui
probabilmente non lo faremo perché noi
nel tempo perdiamo la capacità di venire
posseduti dalla meraviglia la meraviglia
e quella forza che ci accende la
curiosità di capire e di scoprire di
emozionarci
di fronte a fatti imprevisti ed
eccezionali ma non è detto che noi
dobbiamo perdere questa capacità di
meraviglia gli scienziati per esempio i
grandi artisti gli imprenditori
l'abbiamo appena visto vivono nella
dimensione della meraviglia perché hanno
la curiosità di capire e di scoprire e
anche noi abbiamo gli strumenti per
provare a vivere questa dimensione per
esempio immaginiamo una lezione di
fisica al liceo allora prendiamo le due
forze più importanti del nostro mondo
fisico la forza gravitazionale e la
forza di attrazione e di repulsione
elettrica questa è la forza
gravitazionale g è una costante
questa forza e la forza responsabile che
ci permette
di saltare per esempio ho voglia di
stare seduti su quelle sedie ma che
tiene assieme la terra al sole e la luna
alla terra e ma non soltanto questo
i vari sistemi solari all'interno della
nostra immensa galassia quindi proxima
centauri con il sole si parlano grazie a
questa forza ma non soltanto questo
tutto l'universo che noi possiamo
osservare pensate qualcosa come 100
miliardi di galassie e dentro ogni
galassia 100 miliardi di stelle quindi
un numero enorme più grande del numero
di tutti i granelli di sabbia che ci
sono sulla terra
tutti questi pianeti si parlano fra di
loro grazie a questa forza una forza
fondamentale per la nostra stessa
esistenza è questa questa è la forza di
attrazione e di repulsione elettrica
questa forza invece è la forza che tiene
assieme elettrone al nucleo all'interno
degli atomi ma non soltanto questo
i diversi atomi nelle molecole è per
questo che io posso avere una moneta che
si muove così e che è così difficile da
spezzare
perché questa moneta in qualche modo
viene tenuta si veda questa forza tutto
quello che noi osserviamo è tenuto
assieme da questa forza è un'altra forza
fondamentale per l'esistenza del nostro
universo
notate una certa similitudine si le due
forze hanno la stessa forma matematica
soltanto che quella in alto è un po più
forte di quella in basso la forza di
attrazione delle pulsioni elettrica è
4.17 per 10 alla 42 volte più forte
della forza di gravità si soltanto che
che noi non vediamo non capiamo questa
cosa noiosa ma che la gravità domini e
sapete perché questo è un altro mistero
del nostro universo perché le cariche
positive e le cariche negative nel
nostro universo si equivalgono come
numero e quindi si cancellano quindi il
nostro universo in realtà è neutro però
dentro la mia moneta qui ecco che invece
non funziona così ed ecco perché è così
forte e vince rispetto alla forza di
gravità
comunque non importa abbiamo aperto il
nostro orologio della natura abbiamo
guardato dentro abbiamo scoperto che i
piccoli elettroni si muovono attorno al
nucleo come dei piccoli pianeti ernest
router for un fisico neozelandese premio
nobel per la chimica nel
1908 e la dobbiamo pensarci non è questo
che fa sempre ridere perché ero perform
erano moore burbero è un fisico
famosissimo al suo tempo e la va in giro
per il mondo dicendo nella scienza
esiste soltanto la fisica
il resto è collezione di francobolli e
ora fa vinse il premio 9 per la chimica
non l'ha presa bene per niente
d'altronde però lui il premio nobel ha
vinto quindi non possiamo dire niente
ad ogni modo noi è stato il primo a
suggerire che i piccoli elettroni si
muovono attorno al nucleo come dei
pianeti ecco qua poi miniusb or un altro
fisico importantissimo che qui in questa
foto vediamo assieme a quell'altro
geniaccio curioso amante della
meraviglia di einstein neo spora detto
sì è vero che i piccoli elettronici
monotona nucleo come dei pianeti ma non
tutte le orbite sono permesse soltanto
alcune e queste orbite sono chiamate
sono orbite quantizzate e ad ogni orbita
corrisponde un energia e poi a dirla
tutta le orbite degli elettroni non a
sognare per niente alle orbite dei
pianeti attorno sono l'anno danno delle
forme bizzarre meravigliose se fosse
tutto così facile
io adesso vi ho fatto un piccolo pezzo
di teatro e della meccanica quantistica
magari ne parleremo un'altra volta però
vi ho raccontato anche della scienza
vera e se anche soltanto un pochino
io sono riuscito a suscitare in voi un
po di quel senso di curiosità ecco che
ha ottenuto un risultato notevolissimo
perché magari la prossima volta che vi
troverete di fronte un libro qualcosa
dove si parla di queste cose
ecco che avrete già la curiosità di
approfondire e la consapevolezza che è
molto interessante quello che stiamo
quello che stiamo vedendo il teatro
vedete è uno strumento eccezionale per
tutti quelli che vogliono raccontare la
scienza per i pedagoghi per gli
insegnanti per i professori per i
divulgatori per i giornalisti perché il
teatro ci permette di entrare in questo
mondo della meraviglia però attenzione
per meravigliare
la prima cosa che noi dobbiamo fare è
quella di essere capaci di meravigliarci
e non è così facile però non è nemmeno
difficile se noi ci abituiamo a pensare
in questi termini abbiamo visto già dei
relatori e li vedremo tutto il giorno
che ci sono persone che si sanno
meravigliare ecco per esempio vi faccio
e torniamo alla scienza la scienza c'è
un freddo grandissima opportunità per
trovare questa meraviglia guardate
questa foto
questa foto è stata fatta dal telescopio
hubble raccogliendo immagini per circa
10 anni ed è una collezione di puntini
queste non sono stelle
queste sono galassie queste sono
galassie che noi potremmo vedere se
avessimo degli occhi incredibili
guardando l'inter di quel piccolo
quadratino liberate quanto piccolo ha
rispetto al diametro della luna questa
immagine si chiama extreme deep field
adesso voglio farvi vedere un video che
vi mostra quanto noi riusciamo ad un
mare grazie agli occhi incredibili del
telescopio hubble quanto riusciamo a
zoomare all'interno di questo piccolo
quadratino qui ecco qui adesso parte
comincia a queste sono immagini vere a
parte questi disegni che chiaramente
disegnati su sull'immagine guardate come
noi stiamo entrando
e stiamo entrando nel tempo più lontani
noi andiamo e più lontani nel tempo noi
stiamo guardando eccolo qui il nostro
piccolo quadratino eccolo qui e questo
piccolo quadratino pensate a qualcosa
come 5.500 galassie
alcune di queste galassie sono così
antiche che noi le stiamo guardando
appena nate oltre 13 miliardi di anni fa
il big bang è successo 13,7 miliardi di
anni fa quindi quello che stiamo
guardando qui è l'universo come era
appena dopo il big bang
io voglio voglio veramente condividere
con voi questa cosa che il mondo in cui
viviamo oggi è il risultato di uno
sforzo scientifico non è sempre stato
così però adesso lo è fino a qualche
secolo fa il mondo era sempre uguale
generazione dopo generazione cera uno
sviluppo lentissimo un bambino che
nasceva aveva le stesse aspettative di
vita di pensiero di cultura del proprio
padre che aveva le stesse aspettative
del suo di parre così per generazioni
migliaia di generazioni tornando
indietro ma poi è nato il metodo
scientifico e abbiamo capito delle cose
e abbiamo cominciato a sviluppare e
capire il mondo in maniera totalmente
diversa questa cosa e preziosissima
soltanto negli ultimi 500 anni dalla
nascita leggere del genere umano e noi
sappiamo che torniamo indietro di decine
di migliaia di anni
quindi noi viviamo in un tempo che è un
miracolo la scienza nel bene o nel male
ci sta plasmando il mondo nel bene e nel
male chiaramente e i bambini che nascono
oggi hanno di fronte un mondo che è
totalmente diverso dal mondo che posso
avere io che possiamo avere noi allora
abbiamo il dovere credo che l'impegno
che dobbiamo mettere nel generare questa
meraviglia per guardare positivamente al
futuro per creare curiosità che poi ci
porta ad avere la conoscenza e poi ci
porta ad avere la consapevolezza quindi
in chiusura
io io vi invito a cercare nei limiti di
essere un pochino come quel bambino di
prima a prendere il cucchiaio e a farlo
cadere ea vedere cosa succede perché
abbiamo questo dovere e il nostro dove
abbiamo un privilegio noi siamo qui e
abbiamo questo privilegio
io lo faccio sempre porto spesso come un
cucchiaio e lo faccio cadere
wow se come mai accaduto
e questa è la meraviglia vi ringrazio